questo programma è stato offerto da oggi
sarà un episodio abbastanza corto ma
alquanto interessante perché il
primissimo episodio di striscia la
notizia non è come ve lo immaginereste
tanti anni fa in prima liceo poco prima
di entrare a scuola quindi si parla
delle sette meno un quarto segni e mezza
del mattino miss interessavo su un
canale non mi ricordo quale
assolutamente per guardare un programma
chiamato super trambusto
è questo qua
[Musica]
era una specie di striscia la notizia
dove però non c'erano dei veri servizi
ma soltanto degli sketch comici una
fusione tra striscia e mai dire gol
salve salve gaspare momento mario sempre
mai messo le ciotole fuori bravo io non
so quanti di voi si ricordino di questa
cosa qua anche perché molto
probabilmente era una cosa regionale ma
mi piegavo in due veri vere a guardarlo
c'erano questi due strampalati
conduttori e uno dei due era gianluca
ansanelli che sicuramente vi ricorderete
per essere lo sceneggiatore di omicidio
all'italiana il film di maccio capatonda
e di essere il regista di troppo
napoletano e loro durante le puntate
lanciavano questi finti servizi che in
realtà erano degli attori comici che
facevano vari personaggi appunto molto
simile a mai dire gol perché vi sto
raccontando questa cosa qui perché il
primo episodio di striscia la notizia ha
più in comune con super trambusto che
con striscia la notizia stessa
prima di immergerci nell'episodio
partiamo dai due conduttori ezio greggio
e gianfranco d'angelo
ve lo ricordate gianfranco d'angelo io
me lo ricordo molto bene perché è uno
dei primi show man uno dei primi attori
comici che guardandolo mi faceva dire
porca miseria è un talento naturale
inventa rapa tenda in vetrina domani a
minorata grandissimo attore di teatro ha
fatto anche un sacco di cinema un sacco
di televisione italiana
purtroppo però è uno di quei personaggi
che man mano e sempre più sparito dalle
telecamere è rimasto soltanto a fare
tanto tanto tanto teatro ma purtroppo in
italia se fai teatro e non la
televisione se il praticamente sparito
l'ultima cosa che mi ricordo di aver
visto del signor d'angelo e questa
locanda d'angelo questa specie dissi con
quest'app situational comedy dove lui
gestisce una locanda con la sua famiglia
e non succede niente per ogni singolo
episodio semplicemente è una una di
quelle cose che si fa per pensionamento
in televisione ti dicono ti va di fare
una roba col tuo nome dove però ti
diverti davanti alle telecamere
a cucinare un po e tu dopo 50 anni di
carriera di cinque certo ezio greggio
invece per me è difficilissimo parlarne
perché è uno dei miei più grandi guilty
pleasures ogni singola cosa che lui
abbia fatto a livello attoriale a
livello di scritture a livello di
showman aler di comico anche se mediocre
anche se è odiato da tutti quanti c'era
sempre quel qualcosina che mi dice però
bravo però bravo per anni e anni il suo
masterpiece cinematografico box office
3d è stato dilaniato dalla critica è il
pene
ho detto sono dondero della lega diego
dellasega avevano ragione però c'è
sempre qualcosina che mi ha fatto
strisciare da ridere nel film c'è una
singola battuta nella parte della
parodia del gladiatore che secondo me è
una genialata sottovalutata aveo massimo
aveo cesa va cioè lei e cesara buonamici
e lui dice a lecce sarà un perché
sembrava e cesare ma in realtà e cesara
perché lei e cesara bonamici che maestro
cazzo solo dal parametro striscia la
notizia e è molto più importante di
quello che potrei mai dire nella mia
vita non tanto a livello di programma in
sei di contenuti quanto la mole di
episodi che io mi sono portato dietro
per anni e anni e anni c'è il primo
episodi striscia notizia è del 1988 il
mio cazzo di anno di nascita e 32 anni
dopo è ancora qui e a me ogni tanto
capita anche di guardarlo tutti i
servizi di capitan ventosa tutti gli
heat ap ris rotti in testa a staffelli
tutti i cambi di presentatori che ci
sono stati da ficarra e picone michelle
hunziker gerry scotti e questo video
chiude la mia trilogia su striscia la
notizia che è partita con vanna marchi e
continuata con il gabibbo e finisce con
il loro primo storico episodio
[Musica]
prima di tutto dura soltanto otto minuti
perché la struttura era anni luce
rispetto a quella che attualmente con i
servizi con le inchieste eccetera
eccetera
no è presentato come un giornale radio
di italia 1 il cui contenuto è soltanto
una serie di piccoli microscopici sketch
comici ironici con a casa con lui è
davvero difficile
la puntata parte in uno studio orrendo
sembra l'unione di più pezzi di altri
studi tipo ii del pranzo è servito dagli
scarti che buttavano loro ci hanno fatto
un piccolo set che sia lì e se loro sono
seduti su delle scrivanie uscite
direttamente da una puntata dei jackson
ma tralasciando l'impatto grafico la
primissima cosa che viene mostrata sono
le veline che non solo una non sono due
ma sono quattro e arrivano con la posta
pneumatica entrino subito le nostre
veline è naturalmente mentre uno sbuffo
d'aria alza la gonnella
tra l'altro il primissimo argomento di
cui parlano e la strage di ustica
[Musica]
wow è morta gente la cosa carina e che
quando mandavano dei finti servizi tipo
a mosca a parigi a new york
loro sono realmente a mosca realmente a
parigi è realmente a new york in un modo
un po strano e molto [ __ ] come cosa poi
sia greggio sia d'angelo si traversano
per fare un personaggio e devo dire per
essere un format di 7 8 minuti soltanto
comico satirico non è male è solo molto
molto raffazzonato come pacchetto per
esempio in un'inquadratura o forse un po
troppo larga si intravede un cameraman
che scappa all'improvviso dopo aver
filmato il corpo delle veline e c'e
greggio probabilmente per l'emozione si
impappina in continuazione senatore
riuscirà zalone dunque stephanie di
monaco ci ricade è incredibile perché su
youtube una cosa del genere non
stonerebbe 7 8 minuti di sketch e
battute nell'anteprima puoi anche
mettere delle donne perché
effettivamente ci sono nè click bait se
a posto quindi le veline ci sono la
satira c'è chi non fa molto ridere
abbiamo tutti i check di striscia
notizie ma ne manca uno ne manca uno
mancano quelle finte prese per il culo a
silvio berlusconi dove in realtà tu gli
esalti la vita è un peccato
intanto vi potete vedere il telefilm
cinque ragazze è un miliardario
praticamente la vita di berlusconi
principessa
[Musica]
belle
sai
come